hi i'm tm davey i'm an artist living in
bushwick new york
i teach at the school of visual arts and
i've been challenged to create a
self-portrait
in 11 levels of increasing complexity
we're not worried about photo likeness
in these levels but we'll be working
from a mirror
we're interested in the way our mind
perceives
the sense of volumes of the head the
sense of light as it plays across
time good bad none of that matters here
this is about
discovery i'm defining complexity as
the layers of thinking that help us to
build
observational truths that are necessary
for a picture that just somehow
feels right this is my interpretation
the challenge
every level has infinite amount of space
to branch off and discover things that
maybe haven't been discovered
level one solar head the solar head
it emerged on the walls of caves
the solar head is a circle two eyes
and a mouth if you were to ask a
three-year-old to draw a person
they'd most likely start with the shape
of a head
this is an instinctual archetypal
structure your child will arrive at the
solar head
at some point just out of the pure
curiosity to reflect themselves
as soon as that child begins to see the
difference between
one person's nose and another one
person's
eyes and the next we're entering the
next level
level two identifying features
at level two language can be a guide
when you
understand that an eye has eyelashes
there is
often a will to put those eyelashes in
the drawing as soon as we move away from
the solar circle
we are playing this game of diversity
this game
of character people tend to get
frustrated when their language is
greater than their feeling of reality in
the drawing but this is just a matter of
practice
with a different shape of eyes i might
become
a visitor to south park or an adorable
anime figure but while these worlds are
endless
some simple structures of reality might
seem to be hiding from me
level three volumes and proportion
the points of proportion on the human
head exist
really in the basic structure of
the human skull this is skelly aka mr
bones
the truth of the human skull is that yes
the top of the skull might be circular
but attached to the bottom of the skull
is the bone of the jaw
this bone of the jaw tends to have
a sort of one two three angularity
this is me as a disney character you'll
notice
this method of circle and jaw
in the drawings of disney cartoons it
is a simple but slightly more
complex way of understanding what it is
that we're trying to get to
we're beginning with three basic
points of proportion the top of the
forehead to the line of the eyebrow the
line of the eyebrow then
down to underneath the nose underneath
the nose to the bottom of the chin
there is a subtle proportionate
difference between those
three spaces that will allow a sense
of personhood of individuality to the
subject that you're drawing and in this
case
yourself so what we're putting on the
page is
the circle of the base of the skull
the general character of the planes of a
person's jaw
and then we're finding the proportionate
markings that might get us immediately
to a sense of
structure and likeness level four planes
of the head
the planes of the head build on the
structure we just discussed
but what we're looking for is to create
more three-dimensionality from that
structure
first we have to consider the anatomy of
the skull
often the human head can be simplified
into a side
a transition plane and a center we often
think of the forehead as being a flat
plane
but if you really look at it in three
dimensions what you'll discover
is that there is really a transitional
plane
on the side from the temple moving
towards the middle of the forehead and
then a plane
that is more flat than round
at the center plane of the forehead so
side
transition center transition
side the cheeks themselves are not
this sort of round form that we often
think that they are
the cheeks have a a lot of of
three-dimensional direction moving
backwards
across the skull and connecting
the forward plane of our chin all the
way back to nearly the base the back of
our skull what you'll find
is that the planes of the mouth are
often going to look like a mr potato
head lips
so we're not just drawing the mouth as
we think of it the lips and the teeth
what we're really drawing is the
structure
underlying the mouth the orbicularis
oris the muscle
group some people refer to it as really
the muzzle shape of the mouth
but i find that a bit disquieting the
orbicularis oris
the mouth has a side and a middle and if
you can understand the side in the
middle and the side in the middle
and you can understand it also as having
a angularity you begin to understand the
lips sit outwards from the jaw structure
in a three-dimensional set of planes we
somehow
know that these structures differentiate
us
and we like that differentiation often
one of the common mistakes that people
make at this
stage is that they will draw the
eyeball or the eye as too big for the
socket or too small for the socket
because they are thinking of the eye as
being a symbol of
the face rather than being a part of an
underlying
structure as something that sits into a
bone
and muscular form if you look at comic
book heroes
most of them many of them are really
just perfect examples of the planes of
the head
there's not much more to them except a
slight variation of proportion
and maybe a little bit of character in
some of the features
or in the colors of their suits what
you'll notice is that their underlying
drawing is really just the set of angles
that are determined here
and if you've ever wondered how comic
artists are able to
draw in three dimensions so fluidly and
have it still seem
like there is a certain kind of
realistic depiction there
it's because they've just learned the
planes of the head well enough that they
can imagine it in three dimensions
and the structure is advanced enough
that it convinces
us of a more elaborate reality and in
some ways i might as well be wearing a
cape there is a feeling of this reality
as having
a heroic structure that is
not exactly what we're seeing when we're
looking in the mirror
and the trick now is going to be always
looking for these angles
and yet always looking for even a more
observable truth
level five the blocking as i've been
drawing the planes of the head i've been
drawing this kind of frontal
symbolic set of of of planes blocking
in the head is really just remembering
and forgetting
that we have angles and straight lines
that might
give us a sense of structure
i want to encourage if you're following
me along that you find a place that you
can look at your page and look at the
mirror without moving
too much because we're trying to find is
a way of getting back to
looking and looking without having to do
too much
shifting around if my head is tilted
like this
i know already yes i'm looking for
one two three four but what i'm trying
to tune into now
is the blocking that angle angle angle
angle angle this specific angle i can
just sort of mark it out on my page
in long fluid gestural marks
that are straight and angular in some
ways i like to think of it as really
drawing the space around the face
or their placeholders it's like telling
somebody the directions before
they actually go on the journey you're
giving yourself a map
of what the face is going to be doing on
a
basic undifferentiated level this is
your opportunity to measure
in the mirror using the tip of your
pencil and the slide of your
of your thumb you're going to put the
tip of the pencil at the top of your
forehead
you're going to move your thumb down so
that it is now
at your brow and you're going to just
use that same measurement and compare
top of the brow to the nose
and nose to the chin and you're going to
assess what the subtle differences are
between those proportions
and now you're going to take the tip of
your pencil and move your thumb
to assess the same differences in your
drawing the most common mistakes when
we're blocking in our head
is that even if the angle of the eyes is
like this
we just somehow want it to be like this
if the head is turned a little bit like
this rather than seeing
that this proportion is going to be much
bigger than this proportion of the
opposite side of the face
the back plane of the cheek is
disappearing around
the side that we can no longer see we
will somehow
just will that cheek to be apparent in
the drawing
we'll want those eyes to be the same
size
so that we just don't want this eye to
be bigger
and closer and more prominent on the
face i would challenge you to
draw van gogh's self-portrait in a straw
hat from
1887. notice how much the eyes are on a
tilt how close that nose really is to
the side of the face
and my guess is your first try you'll
level out those eyes you'll bring that
nose to the middle
but try it and see
[Music]
wow jordan really picked up on the
displacement of that
right eye the way that it sort of set
below she might have dropped it a little
bit too low
and if we notice she's also doing a
slightly common mistake
where she's just maybe bringing the eyes
a little bit even more towards the
middle of the face that idea of
the head being turned and the features
moving all the way to the side of the
face that's something
very difficult to get but she she's
doing a great job i have to say
jason did what we were maybe expecting
just a little bit bringing the eyes more
level
than the van ghost tilt lucy got a
different feeling in that van gogh that
i really like
but that leveling's in there if we can
notice it the brow is more horizontal
pama did a good job of keeping van
gogh's head feeling like it's turned
in that central form sarah is really
bringing that nose more towards the
middle sarah's really bringing that eyes
and making them more central in the face
so that they take up really the same
amount of space
in relationship to the middle of the
head it really uh
takes us even further back towards that
solar head in a way
even though there is a all of these sort
of centerings and levelings
and shifts of the drawing there is still
by the fact that we know what van gogh
looks like recognizability in sarah's
work
look for these places where you are
centering where you are leveling where
you're creating
some sort of symmetry that may not exist
in actual observation
if you keep making smaller and smaller
observations in block in
you can really achieve a fairly high
degree of realism
i'm going to copy it over in a much
lighter tone
so you can see how the blocking can be a
sort of map of structure and i'm going
to begin now
with the next level level six contour
as the head turns away from the line
of sight there is an edge that edge can
be traced
and we call that line the contour this
contour is a way
of really expressing the subtleties of
shape
the instinct at this point is to
start with a kind of scratchy mark
we think that maybe we're going to get
it more right if we make scratchy
nervous marks
we can allow for our pencil to flow
and be marvelously
attuned to what it is that we're
observing now this takes practice when
we look
at a beautiful eye we don't see a
hundred nervous marks
we see ah the rhythm of the eye this
elegant flow most people instinctually
because of our symbolic values will go
oh i gotta draw the eyes now
move across the face allow yourself to
observe
around the face explore the way your eye
might move
so that you might move from the ear and
down through a jaw
and then up to a brow and down through a
nose we're not worrying yet about light
and shadow what we're really worrying
about
is the forms that feel like outside
edges
this is one of the great joys of
portraiture for me i have never
encountered a face that wasn't a
pleasure to draw
the contours have defined the outside
edge
but internally we may feel that there is
a certain flatness
that we do not feel when we are
observing our faces
from life that brings us to the next
level level seven
light and shadow the thing that we are
trying to understand is where does
shadow
begin and where does it end what we're
trying to first think about is
what is the light source and where is it
hitting our faces
because our our heads are not linear
block ins
there is a contour that will describe
the edge of that shadow and if you
squint your eyes
at your face in that mirror as it's
being hit by a single source
you'll see a shape that just appears
just a little bit clearer
and that's the shape that we're going to
map in now we are still in some ways
looking for a contour
but this contour is no longer on the
outside edges
there is a terminator line where the
light can just
no longer hit it's like thinking like
andy warhol
we're just trying to create the most
basic tones
to give us the illusion of a kind of
simplified poster like reality
pop part is really this game right here
another thing to consider
what's the angle of your light source
the main point of my light source is
somewhere around a 45 degree angle now
the light source
can be moved and you're free to move it
wherever you want in
caravaggio's self-portrait as bacchus
you'll notice the light source is a
little bit more
from above in most of frida kahlo's
portraits she's illuminating herself
with a light source but she's almost
hiding it which is the same for a lot of
the flash photography that is used as a
reference for warhol's pictures
to finish this level all we're going to
do is put in an average
not the darkest element of the shadow
not the lightest element of the shadow
just a kind of middle so we're coloring
it in
in a sense in the next level we're going
to be drawing more
nuanced information across this so we
want the line to be sort of
tight in classical terms we are
beginning the chiaroscuro
the effect of light and shadow across
observable reality
it feels like we are under a very bright
light that is a little bleached out
like there is not this understanding of
all of the other planes that exist in
the light
that brings us to the next level how do
we get to
all of the volumes as the light is
moving across our face
level eight highlights and accents
so as we are continuing the path of
light and shadow
and developing akira skuro we are
going to find the most reflective points
of light and the most
obvious points of dark
the highlights are where the forms of
the face
and anything really are being hit
most directly by the light source the
accents
are those points that are so deep inside
the shadow
that there is no bounced light no room
light no
other light able to reach them take a
look at this value scale
within our human vision we have a range
from
white to black value is every gradient
in between
there is an infinite number of values in
terms of
major steps between values different
systems say
you can cleanly see 10 11 20
steps of value the value scale that i
learned
is the same number system that is used
in the month cell system zero is black
the absence of light no light
10 the peak volume is white
by creating a set of steps you're
beginning to train
the eye to see the nuanced differences
between values every color skin will
reflect in different ways
but almost every complexion will have a
point that can reflect the light source
in a way that reaches our bright
value and as we go to the other end of
the spectrum
our shadows will exist near the bottom
and already at this stage
there is a feeling of a certain kind of
finish level 9
gradients and value at this point we are
really carving out structure through the
use of light
and shadow since we have our highlights
in some ways we can begin to just
follow the white as it diminishes as it
gets darker and darker and darker
up into that shadow line now the point
to remember
is it's never going to be as dark in the
light as it is in the shadow
so the tendency as we look at around the
highlights is
to see much darker values but if we keep
squinting our eyes we can start to see
it in relationship so it might be useful
actually to begin with the halftones
that gradient
just the softening edge between the
light and the shadow
now suddenly the face is no longer this
kind of marvel comic
or this feeling of posterized reality
it becomes a softer reality from there
now we have the tone of our halftone
and the tone of our highlight the rest
is a journey of discovery about smaller
forms
as you discover the point on the
highlight on the cheek as it moves away
you are finding the careful discovery of
really what is the shape of that cheek
how does it get darker this is the joy
of advanced drawing
this is where we get to say ah this nose
is very complex there is a complexity
to life that unfolds in these nuanced
discoveries of value
if we're careful when we take our time
at this level we can
create a drawing that is what most
people would consider
finished but at this point as you're
looking in the mirror and you're looking
to your page
there is a pretty glaring difference and
the difference
is simple your face has color and the
drawing
does not level 10 establishing a flesh
tone
color really has three basic principles
it has
value it has hue
and it has saturation the relative
chromatic strength of that color so that
this orange is a very chromatic orange
orange can lean a little bit yellow it
can lean a little bit red
so when we begin to understand here we
want to think about the rainbow
light contains the whole rainbow it
contains
red orange yellow green blue indigo
if you love newton as i do
and violet violet mysteriously loops
back in the mind
back into red we have this infinite loop
of color
theoretically if we can just understand
that there is this scale
of placement of hue it will help us in
our observation
of color we saw how white gradates
towards shadow
we can see how the flesh tone of our
face
might lean towards red it might lean
towards yellow and it might lean all the
way from
a slightly reddish version of our flesh
tone into
a near blue or violet version of our
flesh tone
and the reason i'm beginning on a tone
page when the pastel has a kind of loose
pastelliness a kind of brokenness
we don't have the effect of the white of
the page always sort of bouncing through
we just have a kind of neutral middle
that's going to allow the color to sit
in a way that feels like the color
itself is the most vibrant not the
spaces between now we're looking for
what we think of as the color of our
flesh all of us
are pigmented by basically the same
particles and those particles protect us
from violet and blue they're trying to
keep
ultraviolet from destroying our dna but
in the same
mechanism they steal away some of the
blue wavelengths
so if we look at our color wheel and we
take away blue we're left with yellow
and red
and that is essentially the two colors
that make up
what we think of as the average of skin
and orangey
some people are a little pinker some
people are a little bit more
yellowish but we are all not blue
if we can just sort of look for where we
sit in that general idea of light and
dark in the average we can find
what we feel is the middle of our flesh
and we're going to just kind of
lay that color into the average of the
light and we're going to lay now the
shadow tone
into the average of the of the shadows
i'm not digging in too much with the
pastel because i don't at this point
want to make it too dense of a material
so that i can't draw on top of it i'm
just going to
give myself a color level 11 color as
value
we have our average skin tone what we're
trying to find
is where the color comes forward is more
saturated
where it gets redder and where it moves
across that spectrum
to silvery grayish greens
blues and violets light is in some ways
predictable red light is a very weak
wavelength and so
if it has to travel a far away to be
reflected back to the eye
through lots of pigmented flesh there
might not be a chance for that red to
make it out
however there is a thin amount of
capillaries in flesh
right next to a bone that light doesn't
have so much far before that bone
is hard enough to help it reflect back
to the eye and so we wind up getting
what we think of as ruddies it ruddies
is an old term the idea of rouge redness
ruddy moments of
red flesh and you'll find those on the
edges of knuckles
elbows on cheekbones the bridge of nose
is
you find that often right where there's
a
thin amount of flesh against bone if
you're looking for pinkness the first
place i'd say to look
is look for those traditional ruddy
places on the on the face
blood is red but by the time that light
moves through that vein
it just can't make it out as red it
comes out as the strong wavelength
which is blue skin is complicated but if
you can begin to
sense where it cools where it leans into
the blues or the neutral
grayer values because orange and blue
make a kind of gray
and where it begins with red you can
begin to almost notice
that the face is essentially rainbows
the game of pastel really is to start
with that fleshy
middle and to just now pick up on all of
the ways the color
not only gets lighter and darker but
moves through the spectrum
and gets stronger in the reds and maybe
a
grayer red or a more yellowy yellow
or maybe just a little more yellow if i
were to suggest that there's a mistake
of observation in color it's mostly
that the value of the color becomes too
dark in a red rather than seeing the way
that a red on the cheek
needs to be a red that is light enough
to exist
near the lightest point we often will
make it a dark red
so that it flattens or distorts what we
feel is the elegant form of the face
i almost want to say level 12
if you want it freedom to live to
discover life on your own terms
these levels can really apply to any
medium taking
these levels into an oil painting to
explore the same
ideas with just a little bit more time
and a little bit more freedom to layer
and to correct as i go oil painting just
gives
a little bit more space to find and
discover
more nuances and more subtleties and
more shifts of light and
little bits of detail that emerge with
the slow reveal of the process i hope to
let myself as i make a picture
be wowed by life
be wowed by new discoveries
of what's just right there moment to
moment the be here now-ness
of painting and at the same time
maybe the ways that they bring up
emotions
and subtle connective thoughts
that somehow i believe make their way
into the picture
thanks wired